hey so was born five years too early
so think of we were the first company to
put 3D models on iti.com and walmart.com
and and H m.com right so these these
were our first design Partners back in
2017.
um back then browsers didn't even
supported uh uh properly supported 3D
assets to be rendered on on the browser
so you know in the early days we're kind
of trying to figure out where's where's
that this technology of value but the
benefit is that because we survive in
our succeeding we have all that
experience working with our Network
understanding what works and what
doesn't and we're able to create a lot
of value for them today welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
[Music]
thank you very very much for joining me
and talking about your own
entrepreneurial journey and your own
history and background today with hexa
looking at the 3D space you know all the
you know all all text tag from content
creation management analysis Etc I'm
really excited to dive into what what
all this means and where this falls into
your own career but I have to understand
how how is it that you decided to be an
entrepreneur instead of being a butcher
I don't get it
well I'm a third generation butcher
that's my that's my first generation
yeah yeah we yeah for all the way from
Morocco so uh third generation grew up
at the at the market
I learned business there uh through
actually serving people so
entrepreneurship is in my heart uh my
dad is an entrepreneur
uh and I I've been building companies
since I was 21. lid's really three
months after I finished my service I
opened up my first company uh still in
the same areas of expertise as my
ancestors
um but after a few years it's kind of it
wasn't there in terms of the challenge
that I'm looking for uh so I decided to
start doubling with the with high-tech
companies my first one was um kind of a
I was a media buyer in an attic company
which is kind of strange because the
differences between selling chickens to
Europe or like traffic from someone uh
you'll be amazed about how how similar
those jobs are depending on what you're
doing
um so for me building hex after about a
year and a half learning the space the
all-night space was
kind of a no-brainer
it was really really interesting and I
think that this challenge really uh
attracted me
and I love it okay so tell me a little
bit about you know what you're doing
today and and I'd love to start from
sort of the landscape of uh you know of
a 3D and a little bit about the pain
point that we're observing here and the
the landscape of opportunity
right so so let's divide it into two
kind of what we're doing so we're doing
something very simple right a lot of
companies are doing the same thing
they're taking a very very complicated
process and they're making it an easy
one right so if you want to create 3D
content or do you want to manage 3D
content today it's extremely complicated
so we just made that process very simple
we work with companies like Amazon and
Walmart and change the way they
visualize and communicate the products
using synthetic data right 3D
and so I do want to make sure because we
we've been hearing about 3D in media for
quite some time but I think probably
most listeners or viewers would think 3D
and say okay great 3D is is what I have
buttons when I go watch Avatar in the
cinema it's a little different in the
way that your you know the scale and the
types of 3D that you're working on what
is 3D in our world when it comes to
Media
right so when it comes to Media it's
typically the customers that we work
with they want to create digital twins
of their Assets Now their assets can be
products they can be rooms they can be
environments they can be pretty much
anything that they're using today in the
physical world and they understand
they're moving into 3D because they
understand it's just a more efficient
way
of doing stuff I'll give you the
simplest of examples right if you're a
jewelry company
and you want to create this amazing 360
of of a ring
you don't even have to to physically
create the ring right you can synthesize
you can create everything in 3D and and
render the video
so instead of moving models and products
into expensive Studios and our polluted
right so all that transaction all that
transportation is polluted you can
simply click a button and solve that
problem digitally and that's just one
you know small problem I think one one
of the most interesting project we did
was with the Lakers and and Snapchat
if you go to the Lakers website today
you can virtually try on LeBron's Jersey
so before we had these type of
Technologies you needed to go to the
physical store now you don't and
technology is improving very very
rapidly
but if you look kind of if you put hexa
like what are the two main problem
clusters that we're solving one is
content creation so how do you convert a
very partial data set into that High
Fidelity 3D model the only machine that
can do that today by the way is the
human brain right so that's what we're
mimicking so that's one problem cluster
that that's massive and second once the
account is created how do you extract
value out of it we see so many use cases
we see a lot of companies that are
coming to us saying I have that specific
problem that specific problem can you
solve it and then for each of them we
build a customized workflow so that's
kind of the platform that we'll build a
place where you can solve all of your
content needs they're synthetic
well was this the a division and the
understanding from the get-go was that
it was a clear that this was the thing
one no no it took us a lot of time to
get there you know going to the
beginning into the early days of
um yeah 30 days of uh of of hexa was it
clear-cut em said it wasn't clear-cut
what was so many pivots so the the
pivots that we've made like product
pivots
uh business model pivots uh uh
technology pivots we pretty much did it
all right so it took us seven years to
get to a place where
we have that initial Market fit to some
of the use cases that we're solving
right the poor serving
um and the main reason is that the
industry right hexa was born I always
say that hexa was born five years too
early
so think of we were the first company to
put 3D models on ikea.com and
walmart.com and and H m.com right so
these these were our first design
Partners back in 2017.
um back then browsers didn't even
supported uh uh properly supported 3D
assets to be rendered on on the browser
so you know in the early days we're kind
of trying to figure out where's where's
that this technology of value but the
benefit is that because we survive in
our succeeding we have all that
experience working with our Network
understanding what works and what
doesn't and we're able to create a lot
of value for them today
how is this economy shaping can you
go with me on on who are the different
players in this in this sort of economy
and Marketplace and where a hexized
positioned and what really you know
makes this economy go around of 3D
content
yeah sure
um so you have content creators right so
if you want to create any type of
content right if it's visual like images
you have 3D Studios but you have a
photographers right and but you have 3D
artists so there's a lot of ways to
create 3D con to create fit like visual
content today a lot of methods some are
physical some are digital but to scale
it you need typically you need the
physical objects whether you want to
scan it or
and now the industry is moving into a
place where you don't have to have a
physical asset you're moving into 3D
first
and this is Shifting the entire way of
you know people are selling products
look at their visualization flow or
their design flow so 3D helps them
from the moment they ID at a product
they think of what is the next
collection I want to design from that
second onward they can use 3D tools to
make their work more efficient
so that market is divided into kind of
two one is the brands
that are designing and Manufacturing
those products second is the retailers
those marketplaces that are selling
those products so these are the two main
entities and then on top of it there are
the marketers here Publishers writes of
websites that drive traffic to those uh
either brand website or Market or Market
uh
retailers websites right or platforms
like Snap Google uh um now now it's
evolving right so you have a lot of
metaverses that are pulling into them
like uh you know one of our one of our
you know
best Partners is epic games and we work
with them to make sure that they have
enough inventory in 3D right so we're
improving their ability to to ingest
content so
all of that stuff is is is things that
we're doing and you see a lot of players
here the tofu right top funnel or you
know people are using this large degree
sales
let's talk a little bit about the role
of 3D in in the world you know and where
we're at and and the way the media is
progressing and where we're headed what
is your perspective on on 3D as part of
our world
but that's a great question so first of
all 3D helps us better express ourselves
right so we're not limited to the form
that we were born with or now you know
you mentioned avatars now it's unlimited
yep uh I think that's why it's so
compelling to the younger audiences that
you know if if I when I was was a kid I
you know I dreamed to be a lot of things
but I couldn't be right I was in this
form
but now with all of those metaverses or
games engines you know you can name it
whatever you want right so there's
buzzwords but there's like you know all
of those endpoints at the end
they give those younger audiences they
give them the ability to better Express
themselves whether it's augmented
reality right like what snap is doing
filters you see that at older audiences
or to be completely immersed immersed in
inside those experiences right so
if you look at the way that the 3D is
impacting uh the world is one it's it's
reducing cost right it makes us more
efficient because we don't have we don't
have physical world limitations
to it helps us express ourselves in ways
that were you know unreachable before uh
and we're we're heading some extent I
see a lot of really interesting
developments in that space and you know
I can't I can't wait to see how it how
it rolls out
are there different are there any
um trends that that were clearly
observing here as to how 3D is changing
Commerce or is changing the way that
consumers make decisions or the way that
they're perceiving some some items it it
sounds like a a really interesting
notion from a consumer Behavior
perspective transitioning from
traditional two-dimensional e-commerce
to a more experiential 3D one
right so basically what we're selling
here is a visual enhancement tool but it
just it helps you get products closer to
your customers if it's through augmented
rally right so if I'm selling a sofa I
can let them put that sofa using
augmented reality inside the rules
so or if it's
I don't know a model shot I can render
images so I can I can
show Shoppers how a specific garment
looks on one's body
and it lowers returns and increases
sales right so it makes everything more
efficient it lowers their carbon
footprint so it's it's also something
that is very positive
um so these are the trends going into
uh into 2023 virtual try on so we just
uh sign a very exciting partnership with
Tick Tock uh where we take tick tock's
ability right so uh uh VTO virtual trial
experiences or augmented reality
experiences
and we give those type of abilities the
ones that you have inside the app we
give them we give those abilities to
websites
um so a lot of really interesting things
are going to happen in 2023 and it's
going to happen because of the recession
because of companies uh pressure to
improve uh their processes and be more
efficient
mom
what are some of the big Milestones that
we're approaching do you think from in
the 3D space or in the intersection of
3D in the world where go ahead so
headsets headsets are not so they're
selling Goods good right so VR headset
are are selling in good numbers they're
not what everybody wanted it to be
but their main issue is that the depth
of use right so how many times I'm using
it per day per week
is really low
and when you have that low penetration
numbers then you understand that this is
not going to be a mainstream media
so until someone invents a device that I
can use on a daily basis all the time
like I use my phone
then these type of enhancements visual
enhancement are gonna be probably gonna
be used mostly from my phone
um so I'm not expecting anything to
change anytime soon unless
you know the apples the rumors or you
know I don't know some some manufacturer
is going to surprise us with a device
that we understand okay this is a this
is a game changer but
you know these are very complicated
challenges to solve these are like very
very complicated physical problems that
that people need to to figure out
um how to make those devices small
enough and comfortable enough for us to
use and then they can start augmenting
our environment once you invent that
device that can augment our environment
all the time then it's uh that is going
to be interesting because the amount of
opportunities that are going to open up
based off those devices are
are endless
where where is hexa today well what is
happening these days with hexa
so a work keep on growing right so we I
think we grow this year from
I don't know 60 to 130 uh we're we keep
on growing
um our customers are pretty happy with
our services even at these difficult
times uh which are challenging for
everyone that is dealing with mainly
retail
um or happiness levels are as high as it
can get we measure them all the time and
we make sure that you know they're
they're uh
um they're they're at a certain level
yeah I I know it sounds funny right it
sounds like High techie but we measure
happiness like we measure sale like the
same way
[Music]
um
and that's it I don't know it's like we
I go to bed and it's like the only thing
I can I can think of is when I wake up
in the morning and go and solve those
you know extremely complicated problems
so we're still excited even after seven
years into this journey
and it's not it's not gonna it's not
gonna stop anytime soon
and how have you grown as a leader over
these seven years running hexa
oh wow
I I can't even I can't even explain how
much I've run as a person you know not
not as a leader not as a manager just as
a person
understanding and being responsible for
Sony lives
it changes you
it's not something that uh I take for
granted uh you know there is always that
you know post imposter syndrome that is
is is over there and you're always
thinking it's like
am I the right person for this job can I
keep on growing this company to a few
hundreds maybe a few thousands uh can we
serve those type of clients right so we
we work with really really demanding
clients and
and start slowing down right it's only
accelerating
um so I think I grew as a person a lot I
think as a manager even more
understanding how to stop being Hands-On
and and just like float or over
everything when we pass that 20 prison
Mark that was really hard for me I'm I'm
a Hands-On person I like to do stuff and
giving that responsibility to someone
else was something that you know I went
through uh it was it was it was hard it
wasn't easy
um but you know we we build our
companies especially when they grow so
fast we build our company every single
year from from the ground up
and we as leaders and and us as
companies we need to make those changes
and unfortunately you know if you can't
make that transition into the next phase
of the company you can you can stay part
of it uh which which is always very hard
in working in a startup it's not
it's not you know applying or getting
into a startup it's not being success
successful in the first six to 12 months
is how do you maintain how do you keep
on learning the new stuff and and the
new skills that are required for the
next level of your role right that's
that's challenging that's the challenge
and that's that's why I'm so excited
that's why you know we haven't sold the
company so far although we have several
opportunities
because building it is so interesting
it's like a living organism
and you know making those changes and
see how they how how the organization
reacts to what you're doing is by far
the fascinating thing that I have ever
done
wow I feel thank you so much for the
time and for your insights and uh and
the open is sharing the story this was
really wonderful and uh can't wait to
Kim Timmy train from the side and saying
what this world evolves to and uh and
it's really uh really phenomenal so
thank you very very much you feel and
best of luck with EXO
thanks thank you so much
thank you